Why is this not legal here? Well, uh, it,
it's considered to be a new drug by the
FDA and that's the number one reason.
There are four countries so far
that have approved MSC products.
There's Canada and New Zealand were the
first to go to Canada and get this done.
Well not for the only, only for
certain conditions. So in Canada,
New Zealand they approved
bone marrow Mscs,
which are in my mind are not
as good as umbilical cord.
And I explained why, um, and,
and then South Korea as
approved and biblical cord
for knee osteoarthritis only.
So the cells have to be
injected into the knee.
And then Japan just recently
approved the same product. That's it.
It's used to treat very
serious acute graph,
acute graft versus host disease in
children after they've had a bone marrow.
That's fine.
Now are there peer reviewed studies or
anything that shows the efficacy of this
intravenous use of these stem cells?
Yeah, there, there are hundreds.
There are hundreds. And my
book MSC, which is, you know,
you don't want to read it unless you
want to go to sleep unless you're looking
for something, you know, it's just,
it really is purely a research tool.
Um, we have 800 references and
we reference every clinical
trial that's ever been
done with mscs and human
beings and there are 800. Okay.
Well I've had some great
results with stem cells.
Doctor Rodney Mcgee in Las Vegas,
a shot a bunch into my shoulder.
I was at the door of surgery. I was
like my shoulders and pain all the time.
I can't do a lot.
Every time I do something I have to ice
it down for a day and now I have full
function. I mean, it's crazy. I mean I
was literally, I mean it still clicks.
I've got some weird shit in there and
there's probably some stuff floating
around in there. But as far as like the
function of my shoulder and the pain,
it's like a 100% I can do
basically everything. Right,
right. Yeah. Yeah. I was 57,
58 years old and this is like what,
four or five years ago?
And both my shoulders torn labor
rooms, arthritis, bone spurs,
like rotator cuff issues.
And I went down and I got 10
billion sales in each shoulder.
I said to the doc and how's
this going to hurt? And he says,
only when it comes out the other side.
But he put it in and it was,
you could feel him pierce the
capsule and you could feel pressure.
And I couldn't flap my wings for three
days, but after that, no more problems.
And this is different than the stem cells
that you can get in the United States
currently? Yes. What's
the difference? Well,
the difference from umbilical
cords, I had a, what is it called?
What's the kind that you can get
here in the United States? Well,
you can use the only thing that's legally
legal in the u s at least for now,
I don't think it's going to be last
much longer as from amnion. Yeah,
there's an exemption in the,
uh,
it's a federal federal exemption for
the use of amnion for wound covering.
And a lot of people have now translated,
now they're using it in
joints and things that,
but you don't think they're going to
be able to do that very much longer?
I don't believe so.
Why is that a,
cause this commissioner FDA Commissioner
has made it very clear that he doesn't
like it and, and they, they really
haven't liked it for quite some time. Um,
because the, the exemption is
for one thing and, and, and,
and doctors are using it for
all kinds of other things.
I don't necessarily agree with it.
I just,
I just know what's coming down the
pike from a regulatory standpoint. Uh,
and, and you know, there've been some
regulatory things that have come out.
They've gone after clinics and you know,
I think they've shut down three places
in just in the last couple of months and
they haven't gone after amnion yet.
But I think they're building their case
for it and unfortunately that's what's
going to happen. So why would they
go after it? That's what's confusing.
If you've seen all these benefits and
I haven't heard anything about negative
results. Yeah, I don't,
I don't understand it myself to be
honest with you. It's, you know,
amnion it's been used clinically in the
United States for over a hundred years,
uh, without serious
adverse events. But, um,
I think it's more about the claims
that people are making because there,
there haven't been studies, for
example, of Amnion, you know,
amnion tissue injected into a joint.
And I think that the biggest concern is
the claims that are being made and maybe
people are being vulnerably,
you know, I don't know,
vulnerable to the economics of
it. I'm, I'm not really sure,
but I know that I just, you know,
I have my finger on the pulse and,
and that's, it seems like they're
gone. They're gone after fat. You know,
we were the first in the world
to use fat derived stem cells in,
in 2006 in 2007,
we published in on using those to treat
rheumatoid arthritis and, and, uh,
multiple sclerosis,
a,
and then a lot of doctors in
the u s started doing that now.
Now there's new guidance to industry
that came out a few months ago that
specifically prohibits using it for,
for example,
taking your own fat, isolating the
stem cells out of it, and then, uh,
injecting them in your bloodstream or
even a jacking him into a joint. So,
um, I, I don't, I don't
really know the whole,
the motivation behind it,
but I know that the,
the very clearly stated that
that's not going to fly anymore.
[inaudible]
yeah.